thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a
liberating wild ride with Steve obam
Margera is free to be clear it was never
a conservatorship he was under but a lot
of people say it was and we're gonna get
right into what happened with the
Guardianship and we're going to get
super duper juicy plus I just want to
say that I'm thrilled with how great he
sounds I mean it's like
yeah this is the third time we talked to
Bam and by far the best one so everybody
enjoy and let's get into it
okay here we go
ladies and gentlemen Bam Margera In the
Flesh yeah man
you've got the rad distinction of being
the very first guest to have a third
episode oh yeah yeah nobody's ever done
three podcasts with us well rock and
roll we have a lot to talk about because
I basically was pronounced dead on
Elvis's birthday December 8th did not
know that I had like gnarly covered my
body was shutting down and uh I went
into four seizures and each one lasting
10 to 20 minutes and on the fourth one I
bit my tongue so hard it was like nearly
falling off it got so swollen and puffy
it wouldn't fit in my mouth and I was
drinking the infected blood which gave
me pneumonia as well
so when Naveed the shaman took me to the
hospital I went in my fifth Caesar and I
couldn't breathe without a tube down my
throat so I woke up five days later
thinking I was there for a couple hours
like dude you've been here for nearly a
week we tried to take the tube out and
you weren't breathing on your own so we
had to put it so I I spent eight days in
there and um dude when they took that
tube out I felt like I sucked on Darth
Vader's dick I had to sip one tea and
[ __ ] Los Angeles all to live long day
you don't remember anything while you're
out no you were your heart was stopped
yeah you have a near-death experience
no I just kind of I just blacked out I
didn't have any like out of body
experience I have before but not on that
one wow yeah now
this this was not
uh a secret this was on TMZ like like as
soon as it happened yeah and I can tell
you that for me
seeing Bam
Bam's on uh [ __ ] ventilator meaning
you can't breathe by yourself you're in
I didn't say that beat that
you're in the ICU yeah Intensive Care
Unit in critical but stable condition
I'm just thinking oh my God like this is
it like uh like and the the
[Music]
what's terrible is that my my first
legitimate thought was [ __ ] bam
better not die dude it's gonna ruin my
tour it's gonna ruin everything
yeah people didn't like that on the
comments yeah they were like Steve was
thinking about this tour
what a selfish prick
but he's saying it to Bam's face and Bam
would probably be like yeah I mean I
would say the same thing
so you guys really look at the comments
oh dude I well just on the Zach one
because I read the first Zach podcast
and I was like Jesus dude these people
are going hard and then everyone was
going so that was one of the things on
the Zach one right okay well I said into
bam and I'm kind of being fun and for
sure you know there's an element of
truth to it but like whatever the most
important thing is that Bam's not dead
yes and uh Jesus that's important I used
to be in the end it's slightly important
I used to be an EMT in the in in one of
the stats that they gave us was when
somebody has a seizure
every one minute of seizing you lose the
same amount of oxygen oxygenated blood
as running a marathon oh yeah so like
when somebody has a seizure for like a
minute and then they're like doing the
Thousand yards there afterwards like
because they're dead [ __ ] exhausted
yeah man I just like drink molasses to
coat my throat I sounded like you for
like a good day
how did you get the voices sound like
you sucked on Darth Vader's dick was it
swallowing that [ __ ] goldfish I don't
know or maybe all those uh other Senior
Week parties that you got paid for back
in the day everybody
talking and your thing was bashing beer
over your head and then drinking it
rocking the Slayer dude the the it turns
out hitting yourself in the head is not
good for you
welcome yourself to every town in
England and then getting choked out and
passed out until you got knocked down
yeah what was on tour that was when I
was on tour with Don welcome to Brighton
England
welcome to Bristol
do you remember
were you choked out by Jean LaBelle yes
maybe yeah we all were that was intense
they said it was too dark to put on TV
because like but basically like died and
then came back and then you're just like
whoa what just happened they're like
this is too dark to put on TV right or
even the Bell does it real quick that's
a deal so fast he gets you unconscious
so fast
um and and yeah they didn't want to use
the footage but having had the
experience Ryan Dunn felt totally
qualified to just go around choking
people unconscious of yourself maybe so
uncomfortable we were on tour and he
would be like to the audience who wants
to come on stage and get choked out and
and I'd be like no dude done don't do
this this is awful this is awful don't
do it here just do it and do it and then
one day I was just awake for enough days
in a row on drugs I was like okay dude I
want this footage done it's okay
that took me out again again six times
in one day wow when you were in your
drug Heyday didn't you have like three
to four Apartments down on Martel in
Hollywood one was a complete skate park
one was filled with vodka and
grapefruits and then the other one was
like a [ __ ]
padkin Budweiser
yeah I saw a footage of you there one
time when you were trying to sleep but
you do you remember that yeah yeah yeah
and you're like nah just let me go to
bed like they're pulling your pants down
yeah yeah where we stripped you Nick I
don't know if we ever did anything with
that footage man we've got a lot of
footage we're gonna make a video of uh
you know Stevo and Bam craziest moments
together like all time that's going to
be epic and speaking of posting footage
you posted footage of you in this uh
campaign situation right before you went
to the hospital yeah and then I think
you deleted it yeah somebody made me
delete it just because they thought that
it was happening at that moment when it
was like eight days before so I I didn't
know that right right somebody was
filming and I was like you know what
this should just be documented in case
there's going to be some kind of
documentary in the future because I
always get my phone stolen or whatever
and then I completely lose all the
footage and uh you know like we said
they wouldn't let the gene about [ __ ] on
TV but how come they could let my
x-rayed little mini hard dick in
February my two inch hose be shown
without an issue right yeah when I broke
my tailbone I got an x-ray at the
hospital you could see my dick plain as
day in the coldness of February and they
had no problem putting that out there as
long as it's an x-ray
controversial and and uh exciting that
as we spoke about the last time we had
you on the podcast which was over Zoom
you were talking about how you don't
have access to your official Bam Margera
Instagram account that you've got to
send stuff to another person and they've
got to like approve it and then they'll
post it but perhaps because if you're
frustrated by that Dynamic you went
ahead and opened up a new Instagram
account and it well it was it was
because I if I can't have access to my
Instagram then I can't follow my friends
and see new skate tricks or see what
anybody's up to so I had to start a new
one and just hit follow follow on
everybody who I used to be following and
then slowly I just started posting
photos and then people just started like
catching wind that I have like another
one as well I think that that this will
get you a lot of followers on Instagram
and that you know um in the past with
your Instagram it's been like oh oh boy
like Bam's on one you know and you'd be
like posting some summer and there's
been a little bit of that with the new
Instagram account but not a lot and like
my view on it is that
you know I I think there's there's
something really meaningful about
knowing that it's coming directly from
you yeah well I just have an issue with
Instagram because
everybody who posts it's always like me
and my friend at the beach having a
blast me having dinner with my pal
having a blast everybody's having a
blast how come nobody posed like this
[ __ ] cut me off and gave me a
fender bender I want to kick his [ __ ]
ass you know like it's all just
everybody's just so happy all the time
and there's nothing bad at all
[Music]
yeah I mean a lot of people take that
approach
um
and and I I unapologetically take that
approach because I just think it's like
a tool for me to entertain people yeah
you know like that's that's my deal I
drive all my different business you know
initiatives by entertaining people and
using that entertainment to draw
attention to so it's that kind of just
worked for me yeah but yeah do we want
to announce what this Instagram account
is
it's just called Captain cream stain
creams no it doesn't yeah I swear
no you're not kidding
it's not Captain cream stuff it's not
captain crazy caption cream
Captain would be
t-a-i-n but it's a t-i-a-n
cream yeah
everything's taken everything yeah wow
there it is so that is so classic dude
I'm
I'm really enjoying talking to you like
you uh are clearly uh in a good place
man it's warming my heart I think we can
agree that a warm heart feels good but
not as good as a rock hard boner and you
know what I'm talking about baby I'm
talking about Bluetooth tablets if
you're not aware of them let me tell you
they're a delicious chewable tablets
with the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis but they only cost a
fraction of the price and if you've ever
wondered does taking a Bluetooth tablet
uh mean having a really good time and
enjoying yourself sexually the answer is
yes I've proven that time and time again
which is why I'm so happy to deliver to
you this incredible deal from Bluetooth
which is if you go to
bluetooth.com and you use the promo code
Stevo you could get an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets for free you
just pay five dollars for shipping now
in order to get your prescription you
consult with a medical provider at
bluetooth.com very simple very easy you
don't have to go to a doctor's office
it's all in one single go if you do that
and an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets are on their way to
you you just got to pay five bucks for
shipping so if you've ever wondered if
it's a good time I can assure you it is
and jump on this deal right now by going
to bluetooth.com and using the promo
code Stevo now let's get back to it
well
when I got out of treatment I I was like
looking really forward to living near
the shaman who was making me Hike 5 a.m
five miles up a mountain sometimes eight
and um I lost 30 pounds in 20 days and
um you know we would do these ceremonies
and [ __ ] but he said that uh the house
connecting to his house is was available
and I'm like this is perfect so
um it's pretty much an Escondido in the
middle of nowhere but it's around a lot
of skaters like the uh the Dern Brothers
is close to Hawk's house Chris Cole yeah
um Colin McKay Danny Way so you know I
could always visit them and I I actually
haven't skated yet because I hyper
extended my elbow with the bone sticking
out my arm is still crooked and I broke
my wrist for the 15th time so I haven't
been like ready to skate yet was that
the video that you posted where you
broke it yeah and it was just a four
foot mini ramp but some little [ __ ] ass
wax to half pipe covering like a [ __ ]
Eskimo Iceberg and of course like an
idiot I don't practice and do a couple
50 50s or fakie rocks first I just
dropped in right to a pop shove it to
install stalled a river when I revert it
slipped out so bad I went and like all
my weight went on my elbow and it bent
back the wrong way and then of course my
wrist got broken for the 15th time as
well so my wrist was in the shape of an
S and then the bone was sticking out of
my hyperextended elbows I'm trying to
make it to the hospital
they had to give me Pro propofol and
[ __ ] to kill Michael Jackson to kill the
pain was that was that in Florida yeah I
think that was on TMZ too that's been a
while since then yeah
um
and uh I mean whatever dude like
skateboarding there's it's our love like
but it's such a well I also noticed that
if you're any kind of overweight
whatsoever even if it's five to ten
pound I mean picture trying to kick flip
a pyramid that you could do first try
holding two 10 pound weights you're it's
gonna take you 30 to 50 tries as you
throw your board and get frustrated so I
don't want to begin doing that again
until I'm up to par the shaman said when
he's done with me because I committed to
90 days with him he said I'm gonna look
like a Greek statue so I'm like all
right then I'll be ready to skate
because I don't want to be any kind of
top heavy off balance which is what the
doctor in treatment said he said if
you're any kind of depressed
um are you depressing like if I am any
kind of depressed it's because I'm top
heavy and I can't balance on the
skateboard how I used to and it's very
frustrating then I'm like eating salads
in there and either staying the same or
gaining weight and I was like that's it
then I type in zypack the Depakote and
all the other [ __ ] that I was on and
all said number one weight gaining pill
I'm like Doc why would you give me this
he's like well it's antidepressant I'm
like but if I keep getting fatter I'm
going to be more depressed you [ __ ]
E.I yeah
yeah and it doesn't make sense it's the
dumbest Catch 22 that well it's
antidepressant yeah but if I keep
getting fatter I'm going to be more
depressed right
so I don't want to take this and if I
don't comply then I could potentially do
another 90 days from not obeying the
doctors I'm done with it all I'm not on
anything now okay so so the uh have you
have you seen any of this like
outrageous free bam [ __ ] I've heard
about it but I've never watched any of
it you know where is it is on Reddit is
it on the comments where do people's
where are you seeing it just if you
Google it I mean I don't know I don't
even know I'm not even gonna Point
anybody anywhere but like I told you
what I said on the last episode of this
podcast about how like the misconception
is that people were taking advantage of
you like as stripping of your rights so
that they could help themselves to your
money but that did not [ __ ] happen
yeah well I I can't even tell you
honestly what the truth is because I
hear different stories from everybody
who I trust to the point where I don't
even know who to trust anymore you know
what I mean like
all right what's up what like what's a
conflicting account that you're not sure
is true
the fact that well I mean I I don't know
if I want to we can we can evaluate it
after
we're not we're not trying to put
anything out that you're not comfortable
with but I'm just interested to know
what well I was already on my way to
treatment in Sierra Tucson Arizona and
um I decided to have one last hurray
because it was um Memorial Day and I was
with Joe DeVito and my brother and like
it's going off the chart you know so
they're like all right one last night
and then you're going so I went in we
had one night of fun the next morning I
got offered to go on this like fun speed
boat and I was like I'm doing the speed
boat before I go and they're like nope
you agreed to go in the morning and uh I
went on the speed boat
somebody found out and Baker acted me
which means I had to pay 150
000 more
um and I tried to get out of that in
Arizona so I went to Florida and if you
say anything wrong in Florida such as
dude this guy won't shut the [ __ ] up be
super annoying I'm gonna kill myself if
he doesn't shut up you're gonna kill
yourself hands behind your back no I'm
just saying he's super annoying I'm not
really
that so is what I said was I haven't
seen my son in 200 days if he's not on
that airplane I'm gonna jump off a
building they're like put your hands
behind your back I'm like for what
they're like you're gonna kill yourself
I'm like I have a movie called jump off
a building before jackass and I do just
that and the pricker bushes in pools I
didn't kill myself in there I'm just
saying I miss my kid was that the uh TMZ
footage of you at the airport that I
mean there were there were a number of
episodes and I think I can help with
this the uh because because you pointed
to a 150 000. yeah and that was not uh a
Baker Act situation as I understand it
what is a bigger act I'm sorry that does
the same exact thing as 5150. and then
there's also a Marchman act too which is
even worse which I had the pleasure to
experience
I think they're all equivalents is what
what different states call it Marchman
act would be Pennsylvania and then Baker
Act is Florida the 51.50 is California
yeah yeah
the psych we're trading cards like that
kind of [ __ ] Pittsburgh oh dude and
then when I went to the psych ward
I covered did not exist it was all these
Lazy Boy chairs that were literally one
foot apart from each other and there was
like 60 of them this old [ __ ]
just coughing all over me and I think
they were giving us like stale bread
with like a piece of ham on it I didn't
eat for eight days in there but
they were like
the the security were they had fun
causing issues you know if there's a
dude waiting in line to take a piss and
he's 13th in line and he makes it all
the way to the front and they got into
this Tiff he's like you know what if
you're gonna call me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] you're getting in the back
of the line and uh you started I'm like
dude you're causing this issue you
should be ashamed of yourself then one
Naruto was jerking off to his own [ __ ]
I don't belong in here when I was in the
psych ward uh
I've watched a guy take a [ __ ] on a
carpeted hallway and then like just plop
himself onto it and use his own body to
just smear it around into the carpet it
looked like he was break dancing
like uh it it was crazy see now these
are reasons to get re-marchment act or
or have to do another 90 days my
interventionist knew that I had the
money or whatever and and he kept making
excuses the first excuse was I was
rocking the same pants for eight days
and I had five days left of 90 days and
he's like you've been walking the same
pants for 10 days I'm like yeah I'm not
trying to get any [ __ ] in here I don't
care they're like you're doing another
90 days then I threw a cigarette out
into a bush they filmed the cigarette
smoking it wasn't on fire and they said
I could have lit the whole National
Forest on fire to do another 90 days
these aren't reasons to keep somebody in
there I had to do over a year and three
months I think when I was only supposed
to do 90. I think we can we can break
this down again the original Baker Act
whatever was going on like and again I'm
gonna point to the 150 000 because I
think we're talking about the same thing
the understanding I have was that when
you were placed legally under a
guardianship yeah there was uh the
guardianship was
essentially for the purposes of forcing
you to go to treatment right but
treatment is not for free like uh
treatment costs a lot of money so there
was
I was told and an understanding between
the guardian and your family like
specifically April and Phil that that
they needed to come up they just in
general like everybody needed to come up
with money to pay for you to go to rehab
and I believe the total of it all was
like 660 000 exactly exactly and and but
the first you know the guardian uh paid
for most of it I don't know if it was
for her own pocket or having people help
I don't know but right right my mind is
boggled from it all the first 150 came
from your family yeah after that that
150 was gone and it was gone then the
the money for Rehab was coming from the
guardian which is so completely opposite
of what people thought was happening
where everybody was helping themselves
to your money in fact it was the
guardian was just sinking hundreds of
thousands of dollars keeping you into
rehab that's where I lose the like the
understanding because I don't understand
what incentive there was for the
guardian to keep him you in rehab
because she was the one paying for it so
that doesn't make sense but that's what
I'm trying to say other actors in the
picture who seem to clearly be
benefiting somehow by keeping you in in
rehab like that's another 90 days
because you flicked a cigarette that's
another 90 days because you're wearing
the same band I don't know what the
incentive was for those third-party
actors yeah but clearly they weren't
getting getting into your bank account
either so that's where I get confused
but is what also confuses me is that
treatment is supposed to get you like
off drugs so they're like what's an
issue I'm like well my issue is alcohol
and Adderall I've been prescribed to
that for 13 years okay well we're gonna
give you Vyvanse propanolol by proprion
like 13 different things that make you a
zombie I'm like I'm I'm on more drugs in
here than I was on out in the street I
remember when I got seven man they
called me medicine boy yeah
in my rehab because like it looked like
it looked like a bowl of cereal it
looked like Lucky Charms or some [ __ ] do
you remember what you were on when you
were in there I remember Depakote being
wanted me too I was on that yeah what
does that do you know I mean like it
would make me a zombie like I would be
like in groups and I'd be like nodding
off but then there was these side
effects of like yeah they made me say
Depakote might give you diarrhea now I
have to take a pill to not give you
diarrhea but then the side effect of
that pill is that you get headaches and
then you have to take another pill to
get rid of the headache so you're
constantly just taking more and more
[ __ ] to get rid of the side effects of
whatever they're giving you it's crazy
who called you medicine boy the other
are like like
in the morning you would go in to like
like if you had any meds you weren't
allowed to have your own meds in rehab
so you would go into like the the rehab
office and like sign out like what your
meds were and so there would be like a
line of people getting ready to take
their meds and the people in the line
would see what I was taking in the
morning and they would be like holy holy
God medicine boy
it's like a meal of uh I I don't get it
you want breakfast no I'm full dude I I
put on all kinds of weight was it a long
process getting off of all that you know
what like you're supposed to really pay
attention to like weaning off like I it
was a combination of like legitimately
just forgetting to take my meds once I
got out of rehab and I was in sober
living then I took possession of all the
meds and it was me having to remember
and I sometimes I wouldn't remember plus
I didn't [ __ ] want to be on these for
sure and when you're in there you could
slowly watch your friends or new people
come in over time them slowly or quickly
gain weight I had a roommate named Big
Ben and he was like over 500 pounds and
I was like so how did you get that way
well he's like well I've been here for
over a year and I came in at only like 3
10 I'm like so you gained nearly 200
pounds in here [ __ ] died in the
sleep from a heart attack oh really
while you were there yeah he would just
sleep all day not make it to class and
then when he would wake up he would
smoke a bunch of cigarettes and then
just eat like a full-blown you know
those Cracker Barrel like cheese bricks
he would just put that on a like a
hoagie roll and melt it in the [ __ ]
microwave it just house that son of a
[ __ ] I'm like dude you're so unhealthy
but yeah but um yeah everybody in there
they all like just slowly gain weights
like damn I remember when you were here
[ __ ] three months ago you were not 20
pounds heavier hey man you don't have to
be in rehab for your weight to fluctuate
mine goes up and down all the time and
so does my health but one thing that
helps me really keep consistent is ag1
from athletic greens ag-1 is the most
comprehensive convenient nutrition
supplement you can get it's everything
you need plus it's totally delicious and
the reason why it's so good is because
it's loaded with 75 different vitamins
minerals Whole Foods sourced superfoods
probiotics adaptogens
I mean the amount of awesome good stuff
that they pile into this delicious
powder which you mix in with a pint of
water in the morning it fills in all of
the gaps in your diet it's totally
delicious and it helps with your gut
health your cognitive Health all of
these great things on top of all of the
nutrition you need I'm telling you ag1
from athletic greens is what I stand by
it's the most healthy part of my life
arguably and if you go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo they're going to give you five
travel packs with the comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition I'm talking
about and a full year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D with your first order
that is if you go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo again I swear by it it's delicious
it makes me feel good about my diet no
matter how bad my diet might be so jump
on that deal athleticgreens.com Stevo
and let's get back to it
you know so but I mean I don't even know
if I benefited or not I do know that
that I was bouncing around rehabs and
psych wards for six months and then I
went into just like a halfway house
sober living and that was the six month
Mark and I just forgot to take meds I
didn't want to take meds I just stopped
cold turkey and uh I got away with it
did you have any side effects from that
from stopping to stop in cold turkey no
no I mean I don't know yeah did you when
was dancing with the stars that was uh
right when I turned one year sober so
from six months to one year
the radar man like I put down the
cameras I just I just hunkered down and
and made it was like a mental health
decision like were you kind of like in a
dark place or were you just kind of
focusing on stuff and happening um
I I just needed to focus on nothing but
staying sober in recovery and I knew
that yeah dude at one point I was on so
many pills at once that my thing was I
would wake up around 3 A.M Sleepwalk
till I knocked myself out like fainting
or whatever and an ambulance would come
they'd take me to the hospital check my
head do an MRI CAT scan realize that am
I okay the very next night same thing
same time I'd knock myself out sleep
more I did this for a week straight to
the point where when I did it the the
eighth time I fell down the stairs this
time and I re-broke my elbow and wrist
which was already in the cast and I told
them that uh I really needed ambulance
this time they're like every time we
call an ambulance they always give the
MRI to let you know that you're A-Okay
and they would send me the bill which I
found out later was two thousand dollars
each time so um I was like this time I
really have to go I got I this [ __ ] is
rebroken again and uh that that's when I
hop the wall and was running to the
emergency room and then this car of like
skaters or whatever well I don't know
who they were but they've recognized me
like Ben what the [ __ ] you doing I'm
like I'm running to the emergency room
because I got a broken ass up with a get
in the car dude I can't believe in your
car in my car let us take you to the bar
and have a shot I'm like dude I haven't
drank in a year and a half and then
they're like come on just one shot I'm
like no man you gotta take they're like
we'll take you to the emergency room if
you do one shot with I'm like fine let's
do a shot so I do one shot which turns
into three or four or whatever but then
I get my x-ray thank God because that
was proof of but anyway the cops got me
they checked my breath I had alcohol on
it which got me Baker acted again I had
to go to the [ __ ] loony bin once
again and um was this when you were in
Florida like
you uh went to there was like a sports
bar and then there was like a strip club
and then there was like just these weird
I don't want to like say like methy
looking people but like I met them that
day I don't know but they were like Ben
we got your back we're best friends all
this [ __ ] somebody told me do some
ketamine that they had on the on the
thing they posted that [ __ ] the very
next day sold it to TMZ I saw that yeah
you like passed out on the bed and they
were like being like just creepy over
your passed out body like just looking
really weird and creepy and it was like
very alarming and upsetting yeah yeah
um yeah dude oh that was that was rough
that was all the trip to the hospital
you did Kettering too
well we went to school
to the hospital yeah hold on
and we're there we're the strip club
coming like high noon so there was like
nothing it was the B Team
yeah did you did ketamine at the strip
club no when we went back to one of
their houses before the hospital yeah
wow and the dude was living with his dad
who was like a preacher at a church and
he was just fed up that we were there in
like midday just still partying he he
was trying to kick us out but then the
kid was saying that uh it's my house and
it's in my name so if you want to leave
Dad you can it was a big [ __ ]
disaster k-hole just like oh yeah and
he's just blasting all kind of moneybagg
yo rap music and [ __ ] just dance
remember that I remember there being
like uh when did you end up going to the
hospital
um four days later somewhere in the mix
I finally West hair I got my ex right
you know I think what was crazy too is
that the last podcast we did with with
bam like we couldn't put it up right
away we recorded it in like I forget if
it was like May and then it was like
months later we put out this super old
podcast and in like the interim I think
all of this stuff happened yeah you know
like where yeah that was checked out
yeah it was kind of counter-intuitive
like what was being discussed on the
podcast didn't really line up with yeah
the meth team
um so so uh you've been able to see your
kid now like that's not an issue
um well yeah he's now in Burbank which
is close but
um for Christmas and New Year's they
went up to San Francisco so I had to fly
there and visit them but they haven't
been home for a month so home being here
okay yeah and I'm in Escondido so it's
like a two hour drive but
um hopefully they'll be back soon I
still have all of his Christmas presents
I got a
Bentley car and a blue Lamborghini car
for him to drive and uh all this stuff I
couldn't fit on the airplane so it's
what is it
whatever date it is I haven't been able
to deliver his Christmas presents yet
it's just it's still the holidays dude
we're good yeah
how old is is your son he's he's five on
Christmas so yeah she's like when is
your first memory it's like six right
mine was way before that mine it was
like three or four yeah I think I
remember like seeing snow for the first
time when I was like two yeah wow okay
maybe like uh I vaguely remember that
four or five but I remember I used to
hold my breath until I passed out and I
I said that
my mom was like that's crazy you
remember that because you were like two
or three trying to get high before you
go
that gateway drug is
[Laughter]
what was the timeline from um you left
Florida and then to now like how long
have you been home or um um when I left
Florida I went right to Vegas to go to
that we are young um festival and then
from there I came straight to uh SoCal
and um
and just started I was staying with the
durhams looking for a place and then
when the shaman told me that his place
was available with the connecting house
and that's when I moved into there but
um I had to get the Bentley shipped out
here and I still have the Range Rover
that I'm trying to get out here because
I I gave it to Carrie Goetz because
um
he has like six kids he's taken care of
and I'm like dude the last time I
checked you you have this nice ass
Porsche but it's a two-seater like you
know if you want to use my car it's just
sitting in the driveway maybe you could
put it up for sale to see if anybody
wants to buy if the price is right and
he did find somebody and then he showed
me a photo of it all shined up and waxed
and nice I'm like now I don't want to
sell it now I want it again
um he better not crash it there could be
beef
how's your relationship with Novak these
days it's good okay yeah I love that
that makes him really happy yeah and uh
and and you're you're able to see your
son
um are you getting divorced well that
was a very personal question that I
would only ask a close friend but here's
a question I would ask anybody are you
still wasting money on overpriced
shaving products because that's silly
I'm telling you man I used shaving
products from Harry's and they're just
as good as you can get man no gimmicks
no like nothing that you don't need and
I'm telling you and love them and
they've got the best deal ever their
deal just got better and better I'm
talking about the Truman shaving kit
this is gonna be a five blade razor the
weighted ergonomic handle the travel
case to protect the blades the Shaving
foam gel they're going to give you all
of that for three bucks
jump on it I've only shaved with Harry's
for years now I love it you're gonna
love it too and jump on this deal
immediately at harrys.com
Stevo one more time it's the Truman
shaving kit everything you need in the
fanciest box yet with colorful razors
man for three bucks dude I don't know
what you're doing here get over to
harrys.com Stevo now let's get back to
it
it's just the issue was I was like Nikki
when I get out of Florida I will move
anywhere with you except LA because
SoCal is where Sheckler's meetings are
it's where I hike with the shaman do
ceremonies and all my silver skater
friends are there if I'm in La it could
trigger a relapse so I'm not moving
there with you I'll move to any city
except there and then I'm like oh so you
finally got a place what town she's like
Burbank I ain't Nikki that's Los Angeles
I'm like I'm not moving there with you
I'm so we're just like
I don't know what you want to call it
but it was weird on TMZ they said that
uh that that Nikki filed something the
custody related yeah but not divorced
right like she wants to be married yeah
but she wants like a custody of of your
son yeah well the thing that I'll always
hear about and she'll never uh let it go
is that when we got into this uh
argument which was basically about
nothing she has this thing where she
answers questions with questions and she
talks in circles and she beats around
the bush so this went on for three hours
Nikki it would mean a lot to Danny way
if you come to his going away party
because he's moving to Hawaii for good
well I'd love to go all right cool let's
go well I'm not gonna let Phoenix sleep
on some cold wooden ass floor all right
well then don't go well I'd love to go
all right cool let's go well I'm not
gonna let Phoenix leave on some cold one
in their foot then don't go well I'd
love to go well then let's go we did
this [ __ ] for three hours till I punched
out a mirror in front of Phoenix at the
age of three and a half or some [ __ ] and
so stormed off and went to the party
without her so because of that that's
when she was like I'm falling for
custody and blah blah blah blah I think
that if we were to be like
Fair
there's been enough like kind of like
alarming stuff that that's shown up on
Instagram TMZ and stuff that there
there's I think a pretty valid argument
for being concerned about what happens
around Phoenix yeah
um and uh I mean dude and and I I feel
for you so much man like I want so much
for you to just get get good right and
let there be no and when I was
constantly living with him and her I
took advantage of that you know like I I
would wanna go out elsewhere and hang
out with friends and whatever but now
that I'm not living with them all I want
to do is play with them watch cartoons
with them and you know spend quality
time with them and she always rubs it in
my face like well you didn't want to do
that when you had the ability to do I'm
like yeah but I had to do a year and a
half of not seeing it I'm in Florida and
and I realized that he is everything to
me and that's all I want to do like
it's like would you realize that how
much time do you want me to do if I did
10 years of treatment that's still not
good enough to you apparently
like
I mean there's there's really two two
sides of it yeah and uh you know because
I follow caption cream stain
I'm able to see more of you with Phoenix
you know I'm able to see more of you
with Phoenix and and it warms my heart
you know like I think you should be with
Phoenix like uh I love that you care
about being with them I love how much
you love him yeah I also see from the
other side that if I'm Nikki and there's
like any one of these crazy meltdowns
which uh you know arguably could happen
you know if there's some crazy meltdown
like like a rerun of uh of situations
that we've seen even in the past then if
I'm Nikki that happens I'm worried about
child protective services coming and
taking being away from me because
Phoenix was exposed to that so what what
that tells me is that we just need we
need to give get you a track record
right for being a responsible like
healthy clean and sober guy yeah and and
not that it's like something that has to
be done but when I do see them I always
bring somebody like the shaman or
Picasso or Beaver Fleming or somebody
that Nikki trusts that is around me to
if anything did happen they would be
able to you know there's this thing that
only Danny Way and the shaman can do is
they say the word oga Boga and I just
shut my mouth behave and do exactly what
they say and I can only speak if spoken
too
yes sir
that's uh that's a start
yeah what uh how long you been at the
shamans for and you because you said
you're doing 90 there do you have a plan
for after you want to stay there longer
um possibility um I mean the house is
owned by his Iranian friend named Yaya
and he went and found a different place
just because Naveed the shaman said
there's like a really important person
coming that committed to 90 days and the
only way that this is going to work is
if because you can't drive a mile down
the street at 5am knock on the door like
timing is everything with him when it's
five o'clock boom boom boom it's time to
hike let's go yeah so it would not work
if we weren't living together it just
wouldn't I I could already see that from
a mile away so that's so you know we
painted this whole garage bought a sauna
a nice bath and a hot tub and and all
this stuff so you know we got the whole
setup going on right now it's pretty
dope
hell yeah I did yeah what happened how I
called is the ice path well we just got
it all and he he's now building like a
frame around it um like a wooden frame
but God does that yeah oh really yeah I
just bought a sauna yeah a nice bath and
a Jacuzzi so the only thing we've done
so far is the jacuzzi and sauna the ice
bath is still getting built the best
sleep I've ever had in my life oh yeah
but man it's hard to get the [ __ ]
it's hard to get it you just got to get
in there mine goes to 33. degrees and so
like you get in there but I can do like
two and a half minutes yeah but uh yeah
I'm trying to get Steve in there dude
I'm scared man it's the best dude it's
like a natural eye navido take me to the
sometimes when we don't hike if my legs
are too sore we'll go right to Encinitas
at 5am when it's like still dark out and
he just gets right in the water and
chills in there for like 20 to 30
minutes I go in for like a second I'm
like all right I'm wet ah did I run back
out I'm like how do you have the
tolerance to do that how much how much
longer do you have in the shamans
um probably about
70 more days or something like that yeah
cool all right
are you gonna be able to
like break out for a week and and come
on tour yeah I'm sure if it's a week I
could do that um I I just know that when
I was in the hospital for eight days
he's like dude we got to get you like
seriously healthy you need to like sign
a contract with me that you're going to
commit to that I'm like yeah all right
so I backed that yeah so she said Naveed
came up with a wellness agreement
one that actually uh is one that um I'm
not set up to fail right yeah people dip
out for a day and do like an autograph
signing with Steve yeah 100 that'd be
cool I mean we'll be able to do that
down south so yeah yeah
um I mean dude I love it man and I'm
rooting for you so much dude I mean
there's always good seeing you come by
the warehouse dude like we like having
you down south yeah yeah
I I like just the whole SoCal Vibe you
know there's so many people always up to
something
um I've been hanging out with your buddy
Zeke the only one that could do a
kickflip on a surfboard by the way yes
he does like Superman finger flips there
are people who do kickflips on
surfboards but I don't know that Duke
does that he's a finger flipped he's so
rad I can't even stand up on a circle
I've tried over a dozen times you know
what it is I just I I can't paddle hard
enough and I always get skipped by the
wave or get pounded by it and I'm never
in the right spot dude I I I used to
Surf all the time and then there was
like a six month like a six year period
where I couldn't stand up and it was my
belly and then also I dropped like 30
pounds and we're at the wave pool in
Waco and I was getting up on every wave
I'm like I just couldn't stand up with
my belly yeah yeah and if I'm in the
water for too long even with the uh
wetsuit on my my fingers cramp up was it
carpal tunnel or something I don't know
what it is but they they cramp up and I
can't move them and it gets really
painful yeah [ __ ] just cold water yeah
it's just it's just cold
um so yeah we've got tour dates coming
up well yeah you better act quick
because oh dude we're gonna surf this
this uh this River in Oregon Bend Oregon
oh yeah that might be fun
I'm stoked we were supposed to try to
we're gonna surf it yeah it's like uh
because I kayaked down one it was it was
gnarly but fun I did it with Steve
Fisher the pro that was right before we
were going off the 101 foot waterfall
Malacca Falls you see that oh yeah it
was terrifying 101 foot yeah yeah I I uh
I'll be super stoked I think it'll be
really like just healthy yeah like to
come out to get you some stage time and
really work on yeah on your act yeah I
think that like
I I can't write your your comedy for you
but I really think you should frame uh
like start by kind of giving some
context you know like who you are like
you know and if you say hey everybody
I'm Bam Margera I'm the Britney Spears
of Jackass like I just think that
[ __ ] hilarious like people you and
just get into it you know like I I think
the the for uh for for your comedy it
makes sense to dive right into the the
juicy [ __ ] I think that by by like
owning up like uh by owning up like what
a train wreck it it turned into at times
what is funny is
when she shaved her head and then had to
get a guardian and was throwing the
umbrella at the paparazzi
I had an artist at my house saying I'll
paint you whatever on your garage door
or in your skate park I'm like I want
Britney Spears at her worst moment with
the shaved head of the umbrella so he
painted this big massive thing in the
skate park and that only to find out
that what comes around goes around and
Karma bit me straight in the ass because
the same [ __ ] thing happened to me
with the guardian and everything and uh
I'm like man yeah talk about your trip
to the hospital that's you know well I
mean which one there's many of them
right the one where you did Academy
before you went yeah well I mean dude
the cycle I was at the I visited you we
went to the when you were in the psych
Corps and I've been to the overwhelming
majority of the rehabs that you were in
to visit me there too and I've been to
some like fancy ones and some like
gnarly ones with some nut-o people I
almost missed the nut of people because
the fancy ones there's nothing really to
talk about and everybody behaves himself
like I almost missed my roommate Kyle
who would just be like the first thing
he says to me bam you're from
Philadelphia yeah you know Newark
Delaware I'm like yeah it's 15 minutes
from me you know that 7-Eleven I don't
know maybe I used to ride my bike
pierced there I'm like great story
oh my God then I'm on the phone with
Yelawolf I'm like so we're gonna ship
the t-shirts to Nashville and then is
what we're going to do is we're going to
Yo bam I'm like what Kyle he's like have
you ever seen that movie Nutty Professor
I'm like I don't know maybe why he's
like have you ever seen that one funny
part with that one funny character I
forget what character but what he said
was hilarious I'm like great [ __ ]
story Kyle can you tell me that one
again
but now now that he's gone and he's not
my roommate anymore I [ __ ] miss his
ass yeah
rehabs really are like some are fancy
and some are dumps and like like like
the the way that they work is exactly
the same way as a gym some gyms are like
expensive for the membership they're
super fancy like beautiful people and
some gyms are just dumps yeah and like
one is not better than the other like
any gym is as good as the work that you
put in the gym exactly and so like you
can get sober in a dumpy ass rehab yeah
you can get you know it's just a
question of if you do the work of
recovery yeah you know did you quit
smoking no um no but I I did for about
two weeks just because my throat
couldn't handle and that pipe being down
there well so the last podcast we did
you had to step out halfway through and
smoke a cigarette but this one yeah yeah
he's fighting through it are you see
mommy you seemed calm yeah great man
yeah you're not balancing your foot or
anything like that yeah damn really
really like I mean this dude I'm really
stoked on on uh like how you are now
yeah you know like
um it's [ __ ] rad dude
um
I don't want to leave anything out man
this is uh an exciting thing like having
bam in the van pretty rad
well I I saw the uh the Wee Man verse
Stevo Escape thing maybe maybe one um
dude these these hikes are gnarly like I
step on the scale and then I do the hike
I'll come back and and drop like a bunch
of like three pounds sometimes you know
and uh but yeah we should have a Escape
Escape
I think that's a huge Banger yeah um
that's what we should talk about is uh
it's like a strategizing
um some YouTube content yeah you know
like like it's such a an opportunity
for you to just build a huge
a huge business Empire by creating
content like if I were you I would be
less concerned about about really trying
to push the boundary to the
skateboarding yeah and more concerned
about developing The Art of Storytelling
yeah you know and like really like
really letting your audience your fan
base
um sort of join you on your journey of
where you're actually at yeah you know
and like when I was living in Estonia
for a year I didn't skate one bit and
then it got so dark in the wintertime
the sun comes up from about maybe 10 a.m
and then gets dark at around two and
it's always dark and sometimes I would
sleep through the daytime I was so
depressed I'm like I'm going straight to
Barcelona I'm living with Winkle and I'm
going to start skating again and when I
was skating every day I learned every
trick back and I was starting to learn
new [ __ ] but always is what happens is I
twist my ankle or some [ __ ] and then I'm
out again and then I have to relearn
everything it's so frustrating I just uh
but I'm at the level of like I've
learned all my tricks back I'm on point
I'm on balance now I can start to learn
new [ __ ] again sure enough I twist my
ankle and then right that's that I I
would urge you to be very careful about
about
um tying your uh your happiness your
your self-esteem you know like you're
you're your mental health to your
ability to skateboard yeah you know
because being realistic like dude world
and slamming hard I was just at the
barracks yesterday this [ __ ]
slammed so hard he missed his whole
board on the 12 stair rail his feet
landed on the rail and he just went
right to his face and chest I would have
been like dude I would have been out for
a month from that he just sat there for
a minute like oh and then he got back up
and started trying it again I'm like
dude that was me I would have been
helpful like Tony Hawk he he ripped his
uh yeah
yeah he's been in a cane for months now
yeah he just rehab surgery but yeah
skateboarding is a young man's game yeah
and and let's look at at how much more
you are than a skateboarder you're
you're way more than a skateboarder like
you are a musician dude you're me I
cannot say enough about how epic your
eavesdroppers album was like that I I
love it so much and you have an absolute
music career there's no question about
that you're a movie director you're a
music video director like when jackass
started I was so just jealous of you I
was like man bam has this this Charisma
he's got this personality that
he can make a video he can make you were
able to make footage completely
hilarious completely awesome without
having to really do anything because
what happened was when I was younger
anytime I would set a goal even if it
was a gnarly goal it would always get
accomplished before the deadline of what
was in my head I'm like after a while
I'm like I'm looking at all these sports
cars in the driveway like 12 of them and
I'm like I got to cover trans well got
to cover slap got the coverage Thrasher
got to cover I have no more [ __ ]
goals well I'm just gonna go to the
college town in Westchester and just
party my ass off
until I die like I just stopped caring I
got a tattoo called professional pilot
[ __ ] on my hand and for a little while
my goal was for me to black out and have
my friends tell me what I did that day
all right
thought it was funny until I was editing
myself thinking that I'm getting gold
I'm like oh I got gold last night yeah I
can't wait to edit it I'm like oh my God
I just told this dude the same story
four times and he's so fed up with it
yeah I ever tell you the time one bro
yeah you did three times already Ben
well let me try it again you know like
this is not gold footage I need to stop
right I mean dude I I just I I know the
inside of you is the most
creative capable motivated just
completely rad
artist you know like you don't have to
ride a skateboard like at a professional
level to be successful in in business to
be successful as a father yeah you know
like both of us have Decades of of
footage of of uh of stories to tell you
know of videos to make and um I just
really and dude anything that I can do
to help you to produce content to just
find like a rhythm in the way forward
where uh where you could be thriving
like I mean dude the potential you have
to thrive in the digital world with the
YouTube and with the with the rest of it
and and to build businesses which all of
the the digital content drives you know
like there's a million businesses that
you could be starting there's a million
like videos you could be making and um I
just I just want you to to kill it and
and I want to help you kill it and um
and I think that we could probably just
wrap this up right now and and go and
and draw on the Whiteboard and figure
out what the next move is well rock and
roll yeah dude
you look good man thanks
I don't know about you but that left me
feeling really good I think that that
was by far the best bam episode of the
three
and um you know I feel a lot better
about that than the fact that our last
week's episode the first ever Wild Ride
episode with no guest which was super
juicy
um got age restricted on YouTube
because when I was going on that gnarly
rant about the death penalty I might
have overused the f word
apparently I said the f word so many
times in a short little space that he
had to be 18 years or older signed into
your YouTube account to consume it so if
you didn't see last week's episode go
ahead and click right here yeah dude
because man that one was killer dude it
was killer
and we'll see you next week
we got some crazy stuff coming up
wild ride's gonna get real wild